so i'm watching this whole matt gates  skates gate scandal unfold in real time  with the same amount of astonishment and  amusement  as all of you and the facts are coming  out incredibly rapidly is this a  trafficking  investigation is this an extortion  investigation  we'll find out probably soon but i will  say this  there is one thing that we can all agree  on and that is that matt gates  needs to shut up he's not doing himself  any favors going on tucker  uh going on a tweetstorm on twitter this  is not how you put up  a potential criminal defense it's not  even how you deal with  a potential extortion ring where your  father may have been wearing a wire  they asked my dad to wear a wire which  he did  matt gates do yourself a favor and stop  talking you've already done enough  damage smearing me  and ruining the investigation otherwise  i might see you  in court